at the muti market in Johannesburg
traditional healers find everything they
need it's a booming business that sadly
takes a toll on many endangered species
such as vultures ealer filly modeless ad
doesn't think much of the practice in
the head for clairvoyance that's what
they say because it can see from a
distance the consequences for the bird
population are disastrous in the past 30
years the number of vultures in africa
has dropped by up to 80%
Andre Volta runs a program aimed at
rescuing Africa's vultures vultures of
the continents waste disposal service
and Asst Calvin Jers they also hindered
the spread of disease what you see there
is how quick and easy it is to lure
birds in to come and feed and that's
unfortunately what a poacher does in
exactly the same way the only difference
is that they put down poison baits they
kill the birds and they didn't go and
sell them for money the illegal hunting
of elephants and rhinoceros is even more
dangerous for vultures vultures circling
over a dead animal alert game wardens to
the fact that something has happened
so poachers poison the birds in order to
avoid discovering only a few survivors
end up in wildlife rescue centers where
they're nursed back to health and if
possible reintroduced into the wild and
a very uncertain future time and again
conservationists capture individual
vultures to find out more about how they
live that's important in order to
protect them
there we go we capture these birds and
then we fit these wing tags to them we
wring them and we also in some cases
harness them to follow their movements
to track where they go to where they go
and find food within their range across
southern Africa and that enables us to
to sort of get an idea of the areas
where they potentially could be exposed
to threats underlay botas aim is to
eliminate those threats as well as you
can so that there will still be a place
for vultures in the skies over southern
Africa